all right let's get directly into
audience questions for the week
first one is one i've gotten from a lot
of people what happens to donald trump's
adult children once he's out of office
the the answer will uh uh depend on
things we don't yet know we've talked
about the possibility
that some of trump's children might run
for office
we've talked about the possibility that
trump's children
or or children in law would for example
run for senate as lara trump is
reportedly thinking about doing
in north carolina they may go back to
private industry
they may be really tied up with
investigations
for some time and that is why donald
trump has reportedly been considering
preemptive pardons for them
what we do know is that their sort of
re-entry into private life
is not going to put them back where they
were before this entire presidential
fiasco
uh for example in new york city uh
wanted signs
have been showing up uh for ivanka and
jared kushner
except they say not wanted they are not
welcome back
in new york city and there have been
some interesting articles written about
how
they are not likely to be sort of like
re-accepted into the
left-leaning new york city social scene
i don't feel bad for them at all but it
is interesting and
recent news is that jared and ivanka
have recently purchased a multi-million
dollar
actually report is 30 million dollar
plot of land
somewhere in florida to build some kind
of estate so
i think that how this all shakes out is
not going to be known until
we see the full resolution of how donald
trump is ultimately going to sort of go
out
is he going to eventually concede and
attend joe biden's uh
inauguration and act like an adult
is he going to go to mar-a-lago for
christmas and never come back
to the white house and not attend the
inauguration and then subsequently
how tied up will donald trump his family
and his businesses
be on the basis of investigations it's
not just the southern district of new
york that is reportedly
preparing a number of different
investigations into possible
wrongdoing by trump and his family there
are other
uh investigators and and state
prosecutors as well so i think we're
simply not going to know now the
other possibility that's been floated is
that the future of trump's children
is in media as media hosts to be
perfectly frank i see that is very
unlikely i think if the future of the
trump family is in media
it would be this idea of trump uh
starting some kind of media outlet an
alternative to fox news
um more in the line of the
conspiratorial rantings of
of outlets like newsmax and oan but it's
really unclear whether trump actually
has the appetite for that
um and it's really not clear that trump
is going to have the app i mean listen
when narcissists lose it is very
demoralizing and they
always come up with some excuse right
trump will rationalize his loss with
it was rigged and stolen plus i had the
pandemic which was just a timing thing
and if it weren't for the pandemic i
definitely would have won
he every narcissist with delusions of
grandeur will not
rationalize losing so that it's not
really losing
but it can often completely take the
wind out of their sails and listen
trump's 74
and it looks like he you know he moved
his legal residence from new york to
florida the
florida there's every indication that
he's going to be doing a lot of golfing
we may not see him do much and it's
possible his kids won't do that much
either
it's very tough to tell we will follow
it and we will we will know more
before before you know it if you ever
feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an ebook
or audiobook
that you can get through in just 15
minutes where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important
insights from 10 different books in an
afternoon obviously it's perfect for
exposing yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video